determina el máximo factor común de
estos mono mios ok aquí el máximo factor
común es el factor más grande que esté
en ambos mono mios hay que tener un
poquito de cuidado con máximo le voy a
poner comillas con máximo en este
contexto porque es máximo en el sentido
de tener la mayor cantidad de factores
que estén en ambos números pero en
tamaño quien sabe porque depende de las
variables a lo mejor se es negativa oa
lo mejor de es menor que a un 1 y su
cuadrado la hace más chiquita bueno eso
es meterse con los detallitos mejor
ahorita vamos a hacer el proceso para
ver pues cómo funciona esta cosa vale y
el proceso consiste en lo siguiente lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es partir
cada uno de los mono mios en su factor y
zación en primos que básicamente es una
combinación de la factorización en
primos de los números y de la
factorización de la parte variable va
bueno déjame hacer eso para el primer
mono mío vamos con este 10 este 10 su
factorización en primos es 2 por 5 ok
hasta ahí dejamos el 10 y ahora pasamos
a los demás
estase éstas es simplemente es una c
esa se me está haciendo multiplicada por
nada y su exponente es 1 entonces
simplemente queda como una c y
finalmente está de esta desde al
cuadrado entonces la partimos como b por
de vale de al cuadrado es lo mismo que
deporte vamos a hacer lo mismo aquí
abajo el 25 el 25 5 por 5 5 por cinco
aquí tenemos sea el cubo entonces sea el
cubo es por c por c y aquí abajo tenemos
de cuadrada déjame ponerle por d por d
muy bien entonces esto de aquí es justo
lo que te digo es como una combinación
de la factorización en primos del número
con la factorización de la parte
variable donde simplemente lo que
estamos haciendo es que los exponentes
nos estamos separando en cachitos en
cada uno de sus factores muy bien ahora
sí como calculamos el máximo como un
factor de los mono mios pues vemos
cuáles de estos números y variables
están en ambos por ejemplo para la parte
numérica tenemos que el 5 déjame agarrar
un color que he usado el amarillo por
ejemplo el 5 está aquí y también está
aquí entonces el 5 es
común en la parte numérica con la ce
pues tenemos una c en común nada más no
hay 12 es acá arriba va y con las
después tenemos estas dos veces en común
estas dos veces en común ahora si lo que
hacemos para encontrar el máximo como un
factor es multiplicar estos factores que
tienen en común entonces el máximo como
un factor de estos números simplemente
55 por c
por de borde pero lo voy a poner por de
cuadrada sale de por de es de cuadrada
otra vez entonces estoy aquí es el
máximo como un factor no en un sentido
de tamaño tendríamos que ver si se es
positiva o negativa o si de es mayor o
menor que uno pero es más el máximo en
un sentido en el en el que divide a
ambos en el sentido de que divide a
ambos mono mios y además es la expresión
que tiene la mayor cantidad de factores
de ambos